Part of the beauty of playing improvised music is you never know what's gonna happen.
You never know what's gonna happen in the moment.
And as an audience member,...
...I love to go see improvised music because I know that I'm part of the music.
Meaning, musicians that play jazz or play bluegrass,...
...or play music that is happening in the moment...
...were also being influenced by the people in the room.
So, we also can't help changing the way that we play because of who's there.
So, of course, tomorrow if I do that song again,...
...depending on the audience or the feeling in the room,...
...or the day that I had or my mood, or whatever,...
...the dinner or how my hair is.
A different life is gonna come to the song.
It's gonna be totally different.
And so, Terri always gets mad at me because I always do the intro different, but it's because...
How everything's a trial?
Yeah, it always feels different.
Everything feels different.
But you know, that's one story that can mean a million different things on different days.
So, sometimes when we tell that story,...
...I think of one thing and then other times, I think of something else.
And I think music should be like that, you know.